always fun when the good doctor and I
can get together we're coming off for
two days uh two nights rather in Phoenix
Arizona uh where John and I spent 45
minutes each night with the audience at
Building Wealth and John we were talking
about anxiety and stress in two major
areas of our lives the two most
important areas of Our Lives
relationships and work right and it was
a lot of fun and we didn't do much
talking we did a lot of listening and
answering of questions as men and women
stood up in the aisles and just asked
question after question and and so today
I would just tell you while John and I
are here we love to combine and talk
about specifically if in your work life
things are really awful I can tell you
you're dragging that stuff home with you
you really are it is having a profound
impact on your relationship so John and
I want to team up and talk about the
relationships the the mental health the
anxiety side of things in your personal
life and in your professional life
that's our particular areas of focus and
of course we'll answer your money
questions so
um hey it is uh it's a free phone call
so there you go jump in let's go to
Catherine who starts us off this hour in
Spokane Washington Catherine how can we
help
about being sued by collections
um and it's on behalf of my 76 year old
my mom
um my 91 year old father was a victim of
a phone scam
um they charged him ten thousand dollars
to
um like a consolidate
um his credit card debt but it was a
scam company
um we found out about it right away
contacted his credit card to let them
know it was a scam
um they didn't do anything about it they
left the charges on his credit card
um and it went to collections right
after that I had their they weren't
ready to let go of their home phone so
it was forwarded to my cell phone so
that he would not fall for any more
scams I have not received any questions
action calls on their behalf but now my
mom is being sued
by collections for twenty five thousand
dollars fifteen thousand dollars of that
was their debt
um but ten thousand dollars of that is
this scam so
um she's going to have to go to court
and I am wondering
well
how I can help because I intended to try
to settle with um collections on their
behalf
um they did give us power of attorney my
brothers they're kind of helping them
out
um but what do you do when you are uh
being sued and not all of the money is
legitimate money that they spent
do you guys ever file a dispute of
charges like a formal dispute
yes yes and they just didn't respond to
that
um they they deny it goodbye they stood
by that oh because my 91 year old father
you know gave these people his credit
card information then that was a
legitimate
um spending of the money
even though it was a scam company they
had they had no intention
um of
ever helping him out of credit card debt
okay what kind of documentation do you
have on the scam company that you can
can you prove to a lawyer if you were
standing in front of a judge or staying
in front of John and I could you prove
that that was an actual scam company
they don't provide what they charged
your grandfather for
he got a letter from some like random
um firm in New York some lawyer it was
just a front situation but they never
provided him any Services
um and they just fell off the face of
the Earth did not reply to the credit
card company's attempts to get the money
back or anything like that do you have
an attorney currently you and your
brother on behalf of your parents
we do not oh you get I got a good good a
really good one yeah uh I I think this
is going to be a pretty slam dunk case
but I'm no lawyer but if I were in your
shoes uh I would be fighting this the
credit card company they're they're not
playing ball but I'm playing nice and
they're not going to
uh and so you're gonna have to prove
this uh you're being sued so you might
as well play ball and win what do you
have in cash or your parents have in
cash that if you were going to settle
this they could write a check for me
down with it
um so my brother is currently living
with them helping them out I live across
the country from them so there's limited
things I can do I'm willing to be on the
phone for them
um but I mean
he could do it
the do up I said if if um we could
negotiate a settlement not including
that ten thousand dollars
um we could come up with the money what
I'm asking is if you get an attorney
that's going to reach out and
first they're they're writing you a a
suit letter right which is usually
threat number one it's just they sold
this debt to somebody that has a front
and they're just trying to shake down
your your parents right some of it are
shaking down further they want their
money back and that's fair and you've
said that right the other is yeah they
just wrote they sold your bad debt
without explaining it to the person they
sold it to that this is no good right so
I would come up with a number that you
could give an attorney and say we've got
7 500 we got ten thousand dollars right
now that we need this settled and we
disputed this claim on this date and
you're gonna I considering to be very
specific here's when we called and made
the complaint here's when we received
the rejection here's the I have all your
ducks in a row and I think we're I think
we're at a point now we're going to call
an attorney that would help us
um navigate this yeah and hopefully you
can have cash and say we're going to
settle it for this we all want we want
to walk away from all this and you're
Grandad's 91 who I mean your dad's 91
who cares about his credit at this point
we're going to settle this thing and be
done with it yeah
like I said I haven't gotten any
communication from them and I have their
phone number
um is that say my mom goes to court and
they make a judgment against them
um at that point like we can't negotiate
anymore correct and well if they make a
judgment and then the judge says this is
what the the payment's going to be it
will never get to court if you get a
lawyer they will settle out it's never
they're never going to go to trial okay
uh the change of that happening are so
small if you did the judge has the
ability to say this is what she actually
owes here's the the gavel right but I
wouldn't lose sleep over that yet I
would get an attorney that's going to
walk alongside you through this process
yeah thank you for the call Catherine uh
it's gonna be okay I'd get a bulldog
attorney and I'd interview two or three
don't go with the first one who uh seems
the baddest uh toughest you know make
sure you feel good about it get a good
idea what you think the steps are and uh
then fight this thing you've got the
evidence thank you for the call don't
move more Ramsay show right around the
corner
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman joined by Dr John Delaney
we're Ramsey personalities we are your
co-hosts for this hour it is a free
phone call jump in at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five have you ever wanted to hear the
most popular calls from the Ramsey show
or do you love a good Dave rant if you
want to listen to our take on current
events uh maybe you just want to watch
some of the best debt free screams that
people love we've got a new limited
series titled the best of the Ramsey
show where you get all of those things I
listed plus more
uh we also hit the current real estate
market investing in how to take control
of your life and money in these wacky
times you can find these special
episodes on the Ramsey Show YouTube
channel or
on Spotify just search the best of the
Ramsey Show check out the best of the
Ramsey Show on YouTube or Spotify all
right let's get back to the phones Tina
is next in Dallas Texas Tina how can we
help
hi hi Tina
I have a question for you all right I'm
coming in a Dylan line
I am a traveling nurse and signing
housing especially when you have a dog
is horrendous so
I'm considering getting an RV or a
motorhome some of that sort so I can
just take it wherever I go have my home
with me
but my dilemma is
I'm selling a house right now I'm I'm
selling it for around 230 000 I figure
if I get a motorhome for 70 000 or less
um I'd only have 140 000 left to put
down on another home
so that's kind of keeping me from doing
it and
uh I think that's it okay so let's let's
just back up here that's a good chance
yeah let's let's go through these
numbers so you have currently listed
your house
yes and you expect to get how much for
it
it's about 230. okay and how much do you
owe on it
nothing oh nothing so you're going to
come into Castle so 230 minus your
realtor fees
no 230 is actually after all the fees
are taken out okay 230 would be your net
great how long do you plan to keep
traveling as a traveling nurse
at least two years two years it's just
you and and the dog
yes what's the dog's name I feel like we
need to know the dog's name
tuxedo tuxedo
so it's just you and Tuxedo now
what's that
he's a cool good door okay fantastic so
how big is literally have no idea what
that's me either I just went with it
you're a better person yeah how big of
an RV because I thought I heard you say
something like a 70 000 RV did I hear
you say that
well I was looking last night online and
they were I was looking at a Class C
motorhome
and they go from
um how big is a class Council for 50 000
to 70 000 is kind of the range how big
is that um
around 30 feet yeah I I mean I don't
yeah license
no you don't need a license no you don't
have a license for that but you don't
need a RV that big is my point here's
why I'm going this route it's just you
and Tuxedo
and I get it I get that you don't want
to have to worry about taking care of
him and so I guess you'd leave him in
the RV when you're working is that the
idea
we'll put a good little fenced yard and
put them in the menu okay so I just
normally we don't recommend that
somebody buy an RV unless it comes down
to the amount of cash that you have and
you have no debt and it's a small
portion of your income but in your case
as a traveling nurse I get it I i j and
you've got the cash I I just think that
I'd be looking at a much smaller RV uh
that's way less money is is where I'm
headed do you have any other debt
yeah I mean you're gonna do this for two
more years this RV is going to continue
to lose its value
so for a two-year short-term play
and it sounds like the way you presented
on the phone call it was really about
tuxedo we we we want to make sure that
I'm not having to dog sit him everywhere
I go and find I get that so I would just
do a much smaller much cheaper RV
and now you've got a whole lot more
money and but seventy thousand dollars
for you in tuxedo it just seems a little
much or if you do the math on that
that's 2 900 bucks a month in rent do
you not find a place for cheaper than
that wherever you go allowed
like 70 grand against 24 months yeah is
29 it's almost 3 000 a month in rent
what are you doing it's just too much
for depreciating asset now you could
sell some of it when you got it when you
sold it right but you're talking about
oil changes and headaches and all the
stuff right I there's something else at
play here what is it
do you have 230 000 bucks burn a hole in
your pocket are you just tired you don't
want to be an apartment dweller like
what is it
no I just uh getting into people's homes
and living in their spare bedroom and
everybody wants to charge overcharged
with their home as actor or the bedroom
is actually worth right now I'm in a a
very tiny little room for me and Tuxedo
bedroom and we got a little tiny private
bath
in these people's home and people are
super nice
but I'm paying nine hundred dollars
over for for how much a week a month
what are we talking about a month a
month a month yeah but you're making
really good money as a travel nurse
yes but people got to remember I mean
I'm not in that position but other
people I get it listen I had a apartment
somewhere where they had you know sure I
like your idea I'm just listen I like
your idea John and I are challenging the
cost I would spend half of that this is
a two-year short-term play but I just
want to be honest with you you know the
tiny room in the tiny bathroom you have
at other people's houses are gonna be a
tiny space in that truck that's gonna be
a little RV and your picture is coming
straight it's going to be straight off
of HGTV where there's this picturesque
background and there's a there's a
motorhome park there and a fenced in
yard have you ever been to a temporary
RV Park
I had I traveled once before and I had
an RV at that time okay and you loved it
I liked it liked it yeah well then go
for it well I say go for it I'm just
challenging the seventh I I just I don't
think it's why if you if you were my
sister my friend uh you're my new friend
I would say seventy thousand no no no no
no let's see if we can find a a decent
decent used RV in the 35 000 range or
thirty thousand I don't even know I
don't even know the prices of RVs these
days John but I just think it's too much
to go for seventy thousand it's I think
it's gonna end up hurting you well that
was the
you've done this before you've lived
this life why are you asking us
because I'm scared to take that money
from the house because someday I want to
buy another house and I want to have
that down payment I love having a I just
moved from another state
and uh or from another house
into a house and I was able to pay cash
for that house when I moved in there you
go so here's the deal you're very very
great you're very smart
and you've got lived experience trust
your body
and your body's telling you this is a
lot of money
especially for what our long-term goals
are going to be trust yourself you're
smart
yeah okay all we did was confirm what
John's saying your body told you yeah
you don't need two Knuckleheads on the
radio to tell you that you're smart and
that you're worth listening to one and a
half Knuckles four and a half there you
go come on John is that fair
you got this Tina just be smart it's a
two-year play You're crushing as a
travel nurse you know John these travel
nurses are still uh at a premium and
she's making really really good money
and uh this is a two-year play folks
anytime you're in a a temporary play uh
and and you got a chance to make really
good money but you're going to be
Transit like this keep your expenses
super super low so that when you come
out of this transient season now you can
really put down roots and she's gonna
have a lot of money I I wouldn't spend
more than 30 35 No and and
always remember the situation you find
yourself in that you're not happy
um
don't overdo it to Jet Jet rocket jet
rocket Propel yourself if you will out
of that situation here's what I mean by
that she's paying 900 bucks a month in a
tiny situation it's not great it's not
fitting her lifestyle it's not fitting
what she wants wonderful
three thousand dollars on the other side
of that is a lot yeah right can we can
we find 1500 bucks can we find 2 000
bucks right is there a middle ground
there and I'm the worst about I don't
like this little car so I'm gonna buy
the biggest truck and then I end up
doing something stupid on the other end
of it find some compromise and listen to
your body yeah usually tells you the
truth by the way tuxedo doesn't care
tuxedo could care less he doesn't care
he just wants a rub on the head when he
when she gets off her shift and wants
his little snack wants to run around and
chase the ball he doesn't care where he
sleeps alright folks there you go we're
going to continue to take your calls he
is Dr John deloney I'm Kevin Coleman
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gazelle was made for you the never
quitting non-stopping gazelle intense
with gazelle you can say goodbye to
monthly fees and experience a seamless
integration with every dollar so no
matter how or where you spend you are
always in control and since gazelle is
FDIC insured you don't have to worry if
your money is safe
gazelle the debit card that helps you
spend and save the Ramsay way
[Music]
the Ramsey show is here for you I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney joins me in
studio we're here for you this hour uh
hey uh we have our own shows on the
Ramsay Network and obviously we always
enjoy uh co-hosting the Ramsey Show
whether it's with Dave Ramsey or with
each other or other colleagues and I
just want to point out that today may be
the day for some of you get a little
breakthrough uh you're burned out right
now
you're an absolute zombie John deloney's
here to talk about the mental and the
emotional effects of that I'm here to
talk to you about what you can and can
do in the office and what's the extra
strategy to get out of that so if you're
feeling a ton of stress you're bored out
of your skull
um you feel no meaning for your work
that's all real and it causes burnout
and John and I can tag team on that so
we're just letting you know we're going
to open up the lines for those calls as
well triple eight eight two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five John here's what I
know I could be absolutely my dream job
I mean absolutely right Square in the
middle of it
and if my personal life has fallen apart
I'm not going to be a good worker that's
exactly right and vice versa right in
the flip side my marriage is just doing
great and I feel like it's one of those
rare weeks I feel like a great dad well
yeah and work is tough and I'm getting
overlooked it bleeds all over the house
I'm dragging that home and I'm gonna
start ruining my marriage that's right
so uh John and I love to do that in fact
we were in Phoenix the other night and
we literally just did yeah you said hey
we're gonna do the John deloney show in
the Ken Coleman show here we go and uh
so it's pretty powerful it was fun stuff
let's get real uh if you want to jump in
on those type of calls let's do it but I
I want to get your take on something
this is kind of exciting John okay all
right uh I covered this recently on the
Ken Coleman show and this is what's
going on
in Corporate America and it just happens
John that this example comes from the
largest company in the world or one of
them okay how about that awesome have
you heard
us on John tell me about it yeah yeah
apparently they ship you anything you
want is it a it's a I thought it was
like a like a river cleanup company no
no no they got all the products and all
this stuff anyway here's the deal this
is from Vox recent article John
um Amazon is facing a looming crisis
they could run out of people to hire in
their U.S warehouses by 2024. this is
according to a leaked
internal research project from Amazon
this is middle of last year
the leaked findings also serve as a
potential cautionary tale for other
employers who are trying to do the churn
and burn
metrics metrics metrics we don't care if
you got to go potty you got to stand
there and get the package filled in
three minutes or less Amazon rules a lot
of companies are trying to emulate them
because the stock price is obviously
there well the rest of the story is is
they're churning through people at an
alarming rate and the point is this
internal study was to highlight hey
we're burning through people so quickly
we're going to run out of that
demographic that we need in the
warehouse so this is a real crisis now
this is what I want you to comment on
um like can we just uh real quick before
we get there yeah think of this sentence
it could run out of people to hire in
its U.S warehouses by 2024.
my first initial thought is well if your
place was worth working yet you wouldn't
well you're exactly right that's my
first oh yeah what do you mean we're
going to run out you mean you're gonna
run out of people who are going to take
your crap that's exactly right and live
substandard and be treated terribly then
that's like
your wife's gonna quit going out with
you yeah right yeah it's not her issue
yeah it's a YouTube because I'm not
worth going out with yeah geez Louise
yeah and so that's why this is a crisis
all right now this is their response to
this so Amazon spokespeople said the
company will count on natural attrition
rates to solve their current
overstaffing problem now I want to break
that down because there's a lot of big
words there attrition over savvy so
here's what that means folks listen to
this Amazon over hired during 2021
obviously people were spending money
like crazy now we're starting to see
consumer spending slow down a little bit
so they've got too many people so
instead of treating those folks with
dignity and say hey we overstaffed we're
in a downturn
and you're part of a layoff this sucks
like normal companies would do
they're saying no we're going to let our
normal burn rate which means burning
through people burning them out to the
point where they go screw this I can't
do it anymore I quit that's how they're
going to downsize their employee group
or taking 800 of them and putting them
in a room and saying look we we need
particularly need help in Phoenix and so
we're offering this bonus to move people
to Phoenix we're offering this bonus to
move people to fill in the blank here
right but no we're just going to let
we're gonna we're gonna turn the oxygen
down and let those of you who pass out
and don't make it that's exactly what
they're problems so and this is this is
on the heels of Bezos earlier this year
Jeff Bez is saying we want to be the
number one company to work at in the
world and their internal memo is going
hey hello we're going to screw ourselves
yes by burning through people too
quickly and they look at their current
thing and they go that's fine
we'll just burn people out now this is
the other thing John that that I want
you to comment on so I want you to that
that view of people I'm just curious
your take coming from the world you come
from uh When leaders you people as just
this I I don't even know if you can view
people's assets and then uh they have
more workplace injuries than any other
company
by Miles they've led the country
in injury incidents largely in
warehouses
the pressure on the warehouse worker
from the time that John Delaney orders
something from your house in Fairview to
the time it goes to whatever Warehouse
Health quickly has to be filled and they
don't let people take breaks I mean it
is close to uh really unhealthy unsafe
conditions because they're burning
through people what what's going on in a
company like that how do they look at
people for real not what they tell us
yeah so I think first there's a
disconnect between the lived lives of
your employees and that spreadsheet
that's telling you you're doing a good
job and that's always a recipe for
short-term gain long-term fall off a
cliff right the more you focus on how
happy am I right now right now
I'm just going to keep eating Twinkies
I'm going to keep not exercising I'm
going to watch another movie I'm gonna
do this that's gonna you're gonna feel
good for a while you are and you're
gonna wake up and you're going to be way
overweight you're gonna feel awful and
your friends will have left you and
you're gonna all right you're gonna wake
up in ashes and this tells me that this
is a company that has gotten like you
said it best really excited by the
Applause at the shareholder meeting
and they have forgotten that there is a
whole bunch of people responsible for
that Applause and at some point they
cross paths right and I mean this is
just a
control burn that's
that's left that's left the control burn
area and it's heading off into to set
the Wilderness on fire here's the deal
folks it's gonna be a mess yeah the
reason we share this is because you got
Amazon workers who'll put up with us for
a while then they leave and you don't
have to put up with this you don't have
to put up with this stuff you know and
when you're in an organization that will
not value people they they value process
over people I've got news for you
they're not going to change they will
just keep going and keep going until
it's too late and this by the way is how
the Mighty Fall I'm in no way predicting
Amazon's demise but I'm telling you
that's a four alarm warning right there
coming from an internal memo right and
the fact is they're treating people like
absolute garbage I reported yesterday on
on the kinkova show there's a company
that a 15 billion dollar company that
does food orders and they've hired
Amazon execs who've come in and changed
it and you're ready for this they they
got they got discipline one of the
managers Warehouse managers got
disciplined because the evening before
a package was not packed in three
minutes
because the employee went to the
bathroom for a few minutes I read the
email on the show
the the the higher up comes in the next
day and sends an email and says what are
we going to do about this how do we
anticipate this gee I don't know how do
we anticipate when one of our people has
to go poop less water less water right
so how do we walk around going what'd
you have for lunch today exactly did you
oh you ate Mexican or was it a burrito
are you feeling gassy do you think you
have to go poo poo later today and when
you go how long are you gonna go for
there's just gonna be somebody knocking
on the door on the outside yeah you're
done you're done you're done come on
Richard what are we doing here right but
it is that type of monitoring in the
name of efficiency right it's become
nannyship John not leadership
yeah Nanny ship we monitored our kids
when they were little right when it was
nap time oh you know look at Ty he's not
going to sleep but look look at what's
happened with the kids you know this
helicopter parenting except it's
helicopter bossing that's it and look
we've destroyed a generation of human
beings by helicopter parents it's the
truth and we're doing it to our workers
and that's the reason you saw people to
buy into your mission come on and let
them feel valued yeah like they're
contributing to the society at large and
then they will you'll have a hard time
you know getting rid of them yeah
they'll stay forever yeah to all the
Amazon execs why don't you try loving
your people why don't you just try
loving them okay and you're so dumb you
don't know I know oh you're a softy
oh my gosh excuse me can't go to the
bathroom oh hey you only have two
minutes we'll be right back this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
the Ramsey Show continues I'm Ken
Coleman John deloney joins me this hour
and we're here for you triple eight
eight two five five two two five eight
eight two five five two two five taking
your money questions taking your mental
health and relationship questions taking
your work and burnout questions we're
here for you we want you to win in your
life let's go to Silva in Houston Texas
Silva how can we help
hey hey guys thank you for the time I
have called a few times so it's a
pleasure to do so again great how can we
help today
uh yes sir so the question is I have a
wonderful career my wife does too they
both are completely debt free and we are
wondering if it would be a bad idea to
clear drops to pursue this business idea
that we have
um yeah that's that's it that's the
question okay so you guys have any debt
what kind of emergency fund do you have
we have
um we have about we have twenty thousand
dollars which translates to about six
months and we have 30 000 outside of
that return on the house uh interested
in relatively safe um safe Investments
thank you for our work so okay great and
what's your joint income
is just under 100 okay what's the
business yeah you said you had an idea
yeah it doesn't mean it hasn't launched
so what is the idea
is to do DIY furniture it's the foot
Furniture uh Pottery paintings and think
of it like the new that's like a new
home goods store guys the brand that you
were wanting to Brand so we're going to
rewind the build and Via that brand
incorporate it's got handmade items such
as DIY Furnitures custom furniture
plates Pottery paintings that you would
have used for decoration got it and so
what's your revenues right now and where
and how are you selling those and what I
mean by that last question is is it all
online are you doing some pop-up shops
in the area I mean what how are you
doing this now and what's the revenue
and currently we have nothing we haven't
started making any income right now
we're selling the beginning stages of
building the brand and creating the
online presence sure um getting in
contact with local farmers markets and
other avenues you can use here in person
to run eventually sell these things so
we don't have anything okay I got good
news and bad news okay the good news is
is you got an idea
um you guys have put a lot of effort
into it sounds like you guys are in
agreement as a couple we want to do this
that's the great news yeah
um the bad news is you're not going to
be able to quit your job anytime soon uh
and I'm just trying to be realistic I'm
not trying to be in any way a
discouragement to you I'm just I'm
telling you that it my guess is a three
to five year play because my advice is
that we don't want to touch that
emergency fund that so the emergency
fund is an emergency fund now the thirty
thousand dollars cash that you have
saved over and above the emergency fund
I like that and I'd like to add to that
but I want you two to start doing this
so let's just start making some chairs
rocking chairs or start whatever and
let's start selling it locally at
farmers markets or flea markets or
antique places and get a booth and let's
just prove
the actual product I love that you're
thinking about brand but the reality is
I think you've got the cart before the
horse here I want to prove that we can
actually sell furniture and decor and
things of that nature and so let's say
that we start out in our first month we
do it on the side and you two sit down
and I'm making this up because this is
the mental process I want you to think
through so how many hours a week you
don't have to answer this but how many
hours a week can we you and the wife put
towards this business and let's just say
it's 20 hours for sake of conversation
all right so we're going to spend that
20 hours around just making and selling
and let's prove that let's say we make
two thousand dollars the first month
again I'm making all this up the two
thousand dollars goes right into ABC
bank account whatever your brand name is
whatever your companies and we're gonna
build up build up build up and it may
take you two years maybe you go nuts
maybe in a year's time you guys can put
your one hundred thousand dollars of
joint income in the furniture Decor bank
account I for anybody to leave a stable
job
and go full time into a business
um I want you to have at least six
months of your income in the bank
and that would be the soonest that I
would make the move to quit your jobs
and go full time into that business just
trying to keep it simple I'll stop there
I hit you with a lot does that make
sense any questions about that
it does it does make sense you're just
allowing me to prepare for the worst and
take it with logic rather than with with
the dream idea makes sense yeah and I
would even say this it's not that we're
preparing for the worst it's just we
want to put ourselves in it there's no
reason for you to assume a lot of risk
with this business there really isn't I
understand well Silva stay on the line
here because I'm gonna ask a Ken a
question on on your behalf is that cool
please absolutely Ken this sounds like
somebody who is more interested in the
idea of having a business than he is in
the actual business itself here's here's
why I'm asking and you take these calls
all the time on your show and so I may
be out to lunch here
I've got friends who do their day job
and then they go home and the moment
they get home they play guitar or sand
furniture down or scour Craigslist they
can't help but doing it and they look up
and they have no friends because they
play guitar all the time and now they're
starting to get a couple of gigs the
business takes care of itself this
sounds like somebody who is very
interested in the idea of brand building
and having a cool website but they've
never even done the thing that they're
about to jump off no could be Silva he
breaks up a good point are you or your
wife into the decor in the in the
handyman stuff of of Designing and then
building furniture from scratch
yes as a matter of fact all of our we
just recently got married in April and
we needed to furnish our new our new
apartment home and I would say maybe 80
of everything that's fair was
handcrafted by my wife or DIY by us and
yeah we've been doing this we get a lot
of Attraction from family and friends
and all of us good I guess you could say
feeling this idea and we thought well
maybe we can monetize this yeah because
of my background in banking I I I I have
the foresight to take care of the
banking side of things and et cetera et
cetera yeah so I think what John I think
what John's hearing and and I think that
was a good question because it's smart
to go okay how much do you really care
about this I but what I do here which I
think you heard is I think you're you're
trying to do so much planning because
you're a banker you're a process numbers
guy and the plan will take care of
itself start making furniture making
something and selling it to people and
then we go oh we sold seven of this
chair but we thought this chair was
going to work nobody gives a crap about
it and so we go oh okay no big deal and
then so we're we're just gonna tiptoe
into this thing and then we're going to
uh crawl a little bit and then we'll
walk and then we'll run and so I think
it's back to that same plan but you need
to stop worrying about brand and all
that stuff and you need to start proving
Concepts and let's get absolutely I this
is this is going to turn off some of the
listeners that's fine uh my son uh shot
a deer last year I just went and picked
up the hide like like they made a rug
out of it yeah and I talked to the um
taxidermist today and he said uh as deer
season's starting I said it's about to
get wild and he said dude we could skip
this deer season and we have a Year's
worth of work already in the building
right now wow so I'd love to see Silva
along those lines make a bunch of chairs
and have people start putting deposits
down on chairs and suddenly get a year
or six months worth of work lined up and
then you can go okay now I've got cash
in the bank I've got these business
going now we're off to the race yeah
it's great great great Point John for
folks out there that are in Silva's
situation John made a great point you
want to get that six months of your
salary tucked away in that side business
before you even think about leaving the
steady job however you make a very great
games lined up let's also have a
pipeline yeah and you should if you've
got if you're able to stack that much
cash you should have a pipeline of
business but you make a very good point
so I just want to reiterate that because
we get this question a lot on the
Privacy show hey when do we know when to
move from the steady day job to the side
hustle full-time well first of all you
have no personal debt okay so you're
walking the baby steps out so you're
you're already through baby step 3A at
least and then we've got money in the
side hustle account at least six months
worth that's the safe play but to your
point a very nice pipeline of future
business now there's no risk here you're
Off to the Races right yeah and the risk
is how well you manage that pipeline
yeah right that's different than finding
stuff to eat and by the way friends and
family will tell you they love something
but they're not going to part with their
money for it right there's a total
difference in friends of family telling
you they like something in the
marketplace yeah that's so true hey
Silva thanks so much
can't wait to hear back from you at some
Future Point send us some pictures of
those chairs hey thanks to Dr John
deloney James and the team in the booth
and you America this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
Dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the Ramsey Show and
we'd love your feedback you you could be
entered to win a 500 Visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramsesolutions.com survey
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsey Show it's where America hangs out
to have a conversation about your life
specifically your money your
relationships your mental health your
work your future I'm Ken Coleman Dr John
deloney joins me we are Ramsey
personalities we host our own shows as a
part of the Ramsey Network we team up
today
for you so obviously we're going to take
your money calls we'll also take maybe
those sticky work situations can I just
tell you that we will change your name
and location if it's particularly sticky
but John and I like those I mean like
they're really like dumpster Fire Work
questions those are fun yes yeah and the
dumpster fire at home questions those
two are good and we'll change your name
uh location if we understand that uh
privacy is needed sometimes but uh so
we're taking all those calls and your
money calls as well triple eight eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to San Francisco California where we
start off this hour Carl is there Carl
how can we help
hey you guys thanks for taking my phone
call
um I was calling because
um to give you a little bit of a
background information I'm 34 years old
I'm a self-employed electrician I
started my business back in October of
2020 and I'm trying to purchase my first
home
um last year my father passed away
unfortunately and
um I tried to purchase his home but when
I was speaking I believe I spoke to two
different loan officers and both of them
were telling me that since I've only
been at that point I had only been
self-employed for about a little over a
year they were telling me that my only
option were non-qualified mortgages
so I was just wondering if I could get
some information from you guys on how to
go about you know purchasing a home
how much money do you have saved up for
the down payment
um currently in my savings I have 375
000
um when the inheritance from my fault my
father passed away without a will
unfortunately so we're going through the
probate process
um you know based on uh the value of the
estate the four siblings are probably
going to get around 380 000 400 000 each
um so there's what kind of thing about
that yeah so you're in the San Francisco
area so what what's the price of a home
that you're targeting
um I think you know anything that is you
know halfway decent is kind of in the
900 000 range you know
um you know when I look on Zillow and I
see houses that have sold recently like
stuff that I would be interested in
actually living in is kind of like right
there in the okay 900s
well you're gonna have a tremendously
large down payment so that's great news
and that should help you John the first
thing that came to my mind is I want him
to talk to our friends at Churchill
Mortgage and tell them you know he
called the show
um here's my situation here's here's the
whole shooting match uh I tell them the
whole story
um and I think they'd work with you
because of the down payment that you
have you're going to be in really really
good shape so I I don't want you to be
discouraged I'd like you to call
Churchill Mortgage uh we'll make sure
that we get you connected to them after
this phone call but with the amount of
money you're going to be able to put
down I just want you to be encouraged
you're you're going to be able to uh
easily uh get the loan the small alone
that you're you're gonna need
do you guys recommend going on a 15 or
yes still putting it yeah
just playing with those numbers listen
when I when I
worked with Churchill the first thing
the guy told me um is incredible man he
said
um I'm gonna sit down with you and I'm
committing now I'm not going to take
your money if this is not in your best
interest that's how they started the
conversation with me okay so great
people and they'll walk you through
here's what I need from you here's why I
need it from you and here's what we're
hoping to do here's the other thing is
home purchasing
um people have stopped taking out loans
it's just kind of falling off the map
and so you should be able to find
somebody that will work with you start
with Churchill because I trust those
good folks yeah for sure it seemed like
when I was looking everybody like you
know everybody was putting me on the
back burner like they just kind of
wanted me to talk to them when I was
like literally a week away from making a
purchase or something like that how long
ago was this hopefully
it was in April
yeah a little bit different market now
there's a lot of mortgage people sitting
around uh playing Wordle right now uh
these things have slowed down if you've
paid attention to the news I I don't
know what was going on there and and
there's no need to try to break that
down I want you to I literally want you
to call Churchill and say look I called
and I talked to Ken and John on the
Ramsey Show and they told me that you
guys can help me um the fact that you're
self-employed should not be that big of
an issue uh given that you've been there
for a year and you have enormous down
payment now you know having that
inheritance needs to be a part of this
conversation so you may have to be
patient are you renting right now
um I'm renting a room right now yeah so
here's the deal
relax and not to say that you're not but
let's get that in let's get that
inheritance let's get that big nest egg
because that's going to be that big down
payment and that's going to be your I
would believe guarantee to get a
mortgage and a small mortgage 15 year
because you're going to pay that off
quickly you're gonna have a tremendous
rate on that and you're gonna pay that
off and uh you're going to be crushing
it hey I want people to hear your story
um what were you doing before you became
a self-employed electrician were you
working for somebody else were you
apprenticing what's the story
that was a union electrician for the ibw
I still maintain my membership with IDW
good how's business going for you
um you know things have definitely
slowed down calls aren't coming in like
they used to six months ago but I'm
still you know getting projects here and
there and it's definitely you know I
have nothing to complain about good you
like working for yourself
um yeah I mean it's definitely been a
reality check there's there's been you
know some very high highs and some very
low lows
um here's why overall I would never go
ahead I want you don't get in a hurry to
buy a house houses are still going to be
there and that massive down payment
through the inheritance on top of what
you already have in savings is going to
be there you're in your first year
so many businesses small businesses fail
in their first year year and a half
you've got a reality check right over
it's going to be year two I know that's
what I'm saying you've made it past most
small business owners and so you've made
it and you've seen the ups and the Downs
let's keep building that electrician
business let's keep going there don't be
in a big hurry uh do call Churchill
Mortgage but really focus on growing
that clientele and that business because
that is going to be huge for you given
your great financial position but but
you should be really encouraged and Carl
it's also okay to get this big
inheritance and park it and to rent your
own apartment for a year and I know
apartment rents are Sky High all that
but there's a a graduated step between
renting somebody's room and having my
own place and man just taking a break
your dad passed away still mourning that
having that money there's just this I
got to go do something nah you really
don't man you can you can do this in
stages and you're gonna not stress
yourself out with a home home purchase
at the same time you're your your
personal business is slowing down a
little bit yeah you know there's
something about people just don't want
to rent because they feel like they're
wasting money and I I just I love to
just remind people uh Stacy and I rented
for two years when we moved here just
because we knew we were planting for a
long time yeah and it just gave us
options we didn't think of it oh I'm
throwing money away every month it was
like okay now I'm buying peace of mind
yes great way of saying that and so just
buying Freedom right now it gives you
options folks you're not wasting that
money all right thank you so much for
the call Carl we love small business
owners the best is yet to be for you my
friend I promise you that and call
Churchill Mortgage they'll help you all
right don't move more Ramsey Show and
more of your calls coming right up
foreign
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more first
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague Dr John
deloney we're here taking your calls
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to Doug in
Sacramento California Doug how can we
help
hi Ken hi John how are you guys doing
we're having a blast Doug what's going
on
I'm in a I'm in in a not great situation
and I'm trying to get some advice
um hopefully some advice that saves me
from going further into debt okay
um a couple years ago I'll give you that
advice you just have to choose to not go
into debt all right now go
okay well that's that's the hard part a
couple years ago I was debt free
um and I went through a divorce and I
went into debt to um to get a lawyer in
order to to
have more time with my with our shared
child and ever since then it's just been
a struggle to survive I'm in a new city
um I don't have anybody else
um to help me take care of him and I was
driving a beat-up car
I had my thousand dollar emergency fund
and I was paying down debt as fast as I
could and there was uh my car broke down
and it's cost more to fix it than the
car is worse and uh now it's already
sold to the junkyard and I need a I need
a car by Monday morning so I can get to
work
um and I don't know what to do I I'm
I don't know what to do how far are you
from how far is your work office from
your house
of 30 minutes 20 minute drive maybe okay
and you can't get to that office any
other way than owning your own car
well I could I could Uber
um my friend you don't have to go into
debt right now is what I'm trying to say
I understand everything you just laid
out and it sucks but you don't have to
buy a car to get to work not in today's
world true or false
that's that's true now we need to get
you a car I'm in no way saying that
you're going to Uber for the next hour
but we don't want you going into debt so
uh is your emergency fund completely
gone
I have no I have my thousand dollar
emergency fund and I have 500 that I got
from the scrap yard for my car okay okay
what do you do for a living man
I'm um I'm a machinist I'm like uh I'm a
machinist and did you move to a new town
so that
because your ex-wife moved to Newtown
you want to be with your kid why'd you
move to a new town yeah yeah that's why
how long have you been divorced
uh the paperwork was completed about
five six months ago okay but the
the process started uh provided write
about it when covet happened how much
debt have you accumulated now
um all of it together adds up to 23 000.
what's all of it together
all of its get so there's 10 or there's
nine that goes directly to the lawyer
there's
um seven thousand on a credit card
there's another 5900 on another credit
card and then there's 800 that goes to
um background because I was out of work
for a couple of months and I wasn't able
to pay rent during that time what kind
of money are you making now
um I guess pretty good I make I make 29
an hour yeah it's pretty good um over
time is yeah it's pretty good how much
time is like um
okay go ahead I know I wanted to know
your overtime how much can you make on
overtime right now
that was it's very when they when it's
there I work it but it's not very
definable I do have a side
um you know I drive for doordash on the
side well and it brings in some but it
helps beat my car up too okay yeah so
you're a machinist which means you can
do a lot of different things uh with
your head and hands correct
yeah yeah I mean I I I've got to tell
you right now
um I would be looking to sell everything
you could possibly sell what kind of
side work can you get over the next two
to three weeks uh make it really good
money jumping in anywhere and everywhere
I mean when you don't have the kids or
when you're not seeing the kids you're
not sleeping uh you're you're doing
everything you can let's get you a five
thousand dollar car or a four thousand
dollar car or whatever
get you back on your feet so that you
can attack this dead again
how possible is that
well I in order to get a four thousand
five thousand dollar car I would have to
go out and get a credit card to cover
the extra
I don't know you missed what I said I
didn't say I didn't say go buy it now
I'm saying go make some money sell
something do whatever it takes borrow
somebody's car you know if you gotta
Uber for three straight weeks that's
what you do but you work as hard as you
can to come up with that money you can
at twenty nine dollars an hour okay uh
in two months uh or less you can come up
with five grand to get a car
in my in my mind the car has to come
before because I don't know how I would
get to all the places that I'm going to
do the work
well I appreciate that it's in your mind
John I'm I'm uh I'm missing the
connection Doug here's here's the thing
let me ask you this Doug why'd you get
divorced
oh man
um
uh uh we weren't getting along we were
not getting along why not a lot it's it
goes both ways it was a lot of her and a
lot of me
um here's what here's on this side of it
and maybe I'm reading too much into this
man you sound exhausted and you sound
defeated
it sounds like you wake up every day and
you first thought when you're washing
your face in the mirror if you even
bother to do it is how the hell did my
life end up like this
am I right
yeah I'm in a strange town in a job that
is fine I'm just trying to hang on to my
kid and let me tell you this you're a
good dad
you fought for your kid
and you fought with every claw and
scratch you could and you're exhausted
and when you get exhausted when we get
exhausted and when we get lonely
we cut corners and we cut Corners man
you find yourself in a hole you can't
dig out of or that's going to take you
instead of two months it's going to take
you two years don't do it man
so it's a matter of like kids this is
scorched Earth this is old school before
everyone had credit cards our dads and
our granddads just had to figure crap
out this is you right now
and it might be two months of you
telling your wife I or your ex-wife
um I'm gonna I'm gonna give up my time
with my little one for two for for 30 or
60 days
because I refuse to put me and him in
another hole like I've done before and
we're gonna get a car and then we're
gonna work like crazy
and then you're gonna look up in a year
and this is going to be a totally
different picture
what Ken and I have the the blessing to
do is to see people in your mess and
then we get to talk to him a year from
now and they breathe different and they
sleep different and they laugh different
and you're just in the hole man and so
we got two guys in the light saying hey
Walk This Way
and I get it's like you can't even see
it like I don't how much possibly
supposed to do any more work
and what we're telling you is just for
just go for it
you got to work your way out of this you
don't want to add another five thousand
dollars in credit card debt at whatever
interest rate you're already at when you
can bust it like we're telling you and
you can buy a a decent little car for
four or five grand that'll get you from
point A to point B or two grand do it
for two grand get a piece
yeah it stop doordashing that's a
doordash can I just say this doordash is
great any all work is worthy but for you
a machinist
I wish I could do stuff that you do I
could be so much more valuable for Stacy
around the house but I'm an idiot okay I
can't fix anything but you are so
talented and you are so needed you could
find work all over the place side jobs
here and there using your skills true or
false
yeah okay
come on Doug yeah do you believe you're
talented or not I'm good with
no I do I could do I could do so much
more than I do go do so much more so
tied down you do you do okay I get it
you got through round one
and you got your head knocked off but
you're not unconscious and you're now
you're on the stool and Ken and I are
your trainer looking at you
we just put your mouthpiece back in and
we're telling you get up and go out
there and start swinging the fight's not
over it's just round one yeah you got
your belt running round one now the oh
we're all watching to see what are you
gonna do next
commit to not borrowing money man move
forward not backwards Doug you could do
this you got so much more strength than
you could possibly imagine believe in
yourself and just go work yourself out
of this hole you can do it we believe in
you this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ram mg
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague Dr
John deloney and we're thrilled to be
here with you today taking your phone
calls Triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go to
Los Angeles California and Drew is there
Drew how can we help
hi Ken and John how are you doing we're
having a blast Drew what's going on
so I have a question about a will about
in 2014 my grandfather died and he had a
substantial amount of wealth
so fast forward to today and the way his
design the way his will was designed was
that it was supposed to be divided up
amongst half to take care of my
grandmother and then half was supposed
to go uh to my dad and uh his sisters
however my grandmother did not want to
honor my grandfather as well so she went
to the executor of the will asked if she
had to do it and they went to a lawyer
somehow they changed the will and that
was not being honored I was wondering if
this was legal or if I should be or if
my family should be looking to take
action on this or what would you suggest
well who so she hired a lawyer
and you said went to the executive
the executor of the will was not was
nobody in our family it was a accountant
trusted by my grandfather right and when
she went to the executor uh she told him
I don't want to honor this can we change
it so they found a lawyer who
somehow found a way to change it
how much wealth are we talking about
here
I I don't have an exact figure I know
that it's a very substantial amount a
substantial like a million bucks
substantial like 100 million bucks what
do you guess
probably north of
5 10 million okay here's what I'm
getting at
um
a I've never heard of what you've
described and I spent my career around
attorneys I know a lot of people don't
want to honor a will but that's what a
will is for it's a it's a legal document
so
um if you have reason to believe that
something nefarious happened like
somebody went and changed somebody's
will and is channeling money elsewhere
then you can go get an attorney and
fight that that's your legal recourse
um
I'm kind of torn because
I mean it's a declaration of war against
your family right but also your
grandmother doing that is also a
declaration of war against her against
your family so I mean it's it's kind of
Tit for Tat yeah I just am curious John
I I if the the lawyer can't do it I mean
yeah I've never heard it so who what
you're not I don't know the rest of the
story and I'm not sure you know the rest
of the story meaning when the lawyer who
was hired by the executor and grandma
got the will change did it go before a
judge
so as far as far as I know no however
apparently there was a legal loophole
where my grandmother did not have to
honor this will
I've never heard yeah we're not
legalizing points so we can't there's
there's very little we can do other than
to say if you want to challenge this you
want to sue your grandma I'll go go go
get a lawyer and tell the lawyer the
story but you better have your facts
before you start spending all your money
you don't have you don't have a claim to
the suit because you're not a you're not
a beneficiary in the world your dad does
so your dad's gonna have to sue his mom
and take it to the bottom of it that's
right
sorry and then yeah that that's no
that's that's the other part of it it's
just kind of disgusting I've watched a
lot of Matlock when I was growing up you
don't even he doesn't even know who that
is I'm sure he's too young Matt luck
yeah we're not lawyers here's the messy
thing
um my guess is there's a lot more mess
in this family oh I was getting ready to
say to you what are you see in that we
got Grandma Ma and she's going I don't
want my kids to get the money or
Grandma's got Dementia or an attorney
friend or the accountant reached out and
said hey there's a way we don't have to
give this money away there's a lot below
the surface here A whole bunch um he
thinks Thanksgiving dinner's not been
very warm exactly so here's the deal
you're you can sue your grandma and you
can hire an attorney to do a forensics
accounting of what what the will
original will was and where's the assets
and who's got them and why and who tried
to change it is there any criminal
whatever you can do that absolutely oh
sure and thanksgiving's different
forever it's already different I think
it already is it already is probably
hadn't been very nice for a long time
that's right that's unfortunate sorry
brother yeah sorry that we aren't uh
legal experts but I would talk to Pops
and he needs to fight if he wants to
fight every time he's an attorney yeah
let's get to uh Cincinnati Ohio Brady is
there Brady how can we help
hey everybody how are you guys or sorry
you're ready you're Brady
[Laughter]
what's going on man we're doing great
how can we help
so
um my grandpa told me about
um Dave Ramsey a couple years ago didn't
really listen didn't really think I
would need it and then I find myself
almost 400 negative on my bank account
so I start looking at Dave Ramsey
finally and I've been looking for about
a week now my wife's on board with it
but we just have absolutely no idea
where to start all right give us a
picture a push or some advice all right
we'll give you some advice within the
baby steps which are pretty simple to
understand give us a picture of what's
going on with you financially let's
start with debt
okay uh that so we've got
um
mortgage about 150 I've got a truck of
about 40 000 which I know is ridiculous
that's probably the first thing I need
to take care of yeah
um well let's stay right there let's get
some let's get some momentum on the
truck how much is that truck worth
it's only worth about 37 private sale
based on Kelly Blue Book
okay keep going with the car what's the
car
okay and then my wife's car
um it's worth like 13 she has about nine
on it
so we've got a little bit equity in that
one
um and then we've got various credit
card debts uh personal loan
and then a lot of medical debt as well
how much credit card debt
total like five grand okay what's the
medical debt
to get it all together but I would say
probably close to to 10 grand maybe a
little bit under 10 grand okay
all right and what do you have in
savings any cash
I've got no Savings in cash all right
what's your income
uh I make about 46 I get a raise in nine
days and I'll be making 56. what year
does your wife work outside the home
she uh only works every Friday and gets
paid a hundred dollars every Friday do
you guys have kiddos
we do we have two okay
all right John you want to walk you
through the baby steps or I mean is this
tag team here uh so first one thing
we're going to do is
oh man you got a mess on your hands um
actually you got a mess in your hands
but you can you can start cleaning this
up today
so here's baby step one
you're going to sell some stuff and get
a thousand dollars in the savings
account
full stop and we are working on that
we've got everything on Facebook
Marketplace there you go
everything I want those two kids to be
like are you are we going on the
marketplace right that's that's the goal
right everything right your old guitars
that you're like no dude I'm gonna get
the band back together you're not right
now you're not right you got two mowers
because you're that guy sell one of them
right whatever you got to do
um
you've got a truck that is about your
annual income that's what you owe on it
that's Insanity you know that right I
know I I 100 agree I would probably if I
find myself in your situation I would go
down to
um take both cars and sell them both
and leave with two old used Camrys
that's what I would do
okay okay this is a an emergency
situation you got two little kids and
you've got negative dollars in your
checking account this is not a time to
be like yeah but that man you're a long
way off from that got it
right um and let me back up before you
get the thousand dollar emergency fund
dude you need to have a target of what
you're trying to hit you've got to be a
grown-up and go get your pull your
credit report from one or two of the um
one or two of the service the service
providers and you've got to know exactly
how much you owe in order uh from
smallest to largest right and you're
gonna go through these things and start
knocking them off one at a time one at a
time one at a time you're gonna work
extra your wife's probably gonna have to
work you're gonna have to call on people
to keep the kids you're gonna have to
get after it Brady you can do this hang
on the line we're gonna gift you a free
membership trial membership whatever we
do guys uh to FPU Financial Peace
University you gotta watch the video
listen you gotta stay with it let's give
you Total Money Makeover as well and
John's right I'd sell those cars
instantly and work more over time side
jobs than you ever have in your life
you're really close to getting out of
this you can do this
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman my colleague is Dr John deloney
joins me this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the phone
number eight eight two five five two two
five Hey listen folks we want to know
what you think we really do and who
doesn't love their own opinion
yeah that's what I used to love about
the old school Like Tonight Show and Jay
Leno would you know they take a camera
out on the street you stick a microphone
and a camera in someone's face and ask
them anything most people are like no
idea what I'm being asked but I'm gonna
answer anyway it sounds like the
internet yeah we don't want that kind of
opinion but we do want those of you who
love the show who digest the show
however you do to give us your feedback
so that we're bringing you more of what
you want
so one way you could do this by answer a
few questions in a new show survey we
just launched you can check it out at
ramseysolutions.com survey that is the
website uh ramsesolutions.com survey it
only takes a few minutes and uh we're
we're going to try to incentivize you a
500 Visa gift card is up for grabs uh
and I guess you become eligible for that
when you go to Ramsey Solutions
Ramsay Solutions rather can't talk
john.com slash survey
ramsaysolutions.com survey tell us what
you think be kind be gentle but be
honest actually be honest I'm not going
to read it
somebody else they'll read it to us
they'll tell us yeah yeah it's great all
right back to the phones we go
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania home of the
Steelers John is there John how can we
help
hey guys how you doing thanks for taking
my call you bet what's up
uh so a couple questions
um both kind of revolved around pausing
the baby steps if possible
um one is about getting a house we have
a house it's a townhouse and we're
looking to upgrade two kids boy girl we
only have two bedrooms so we want them
to have separate bedrooms eventually
um in an emergency fund if I dip into it
do I pause the baby steps to pay it back
well first don't dip into your emergency
fund for something that's not an
emergency
so so we did this there it was it was a
surgery my wife had would that be
considered
there's a few thousand dollars and we
didn't know if we should cash flow it
which it might take a little bit of time
but they started to come in so we took a
couple thousand to start the pay I would
not call that an emergency uh if you if
you could cash flow it and remember
emergency fund is for that true
emergency something comes out up out of
nowhere
and we didn't plan for it and it is a
significant expense since it needs to be
paid and needs to be dealt with right
now that's that's how we would define an
emergency am I right yeah I had a
procedure done a few weeks ago but I
knew it was coming a couple months in
advance and so we my wife and I prepared
for it so it is what we didn't know was
coming so I didn't know how okay sure
yeah yeah I mean if you all sudden you
need emergency surgery or hey you gotta
you have to have surgery next week yeah
that's what the emergency how much did
you take out
it was 3 000 out of it all right so are
you asking if you pause the baby steps
until you replenish
yeah do we pause because we could pay it
back within a month if we but I but I
pause the investing in my kids college
and those things to pay it back real
quick or do we just slowly cash flows
back no slowly cash flow back you
wouldn't pause the rest of the baby
steps I mean it's three grand you guys
are doing okay correct right right yes
yeah yeah we're about a year out of debt
good man good for you man listen I
listen John I know what you're talking
about I had I had a uh I had a uh well I
had an idiot moment it's probably worth
sharing uh I had a small leak in my
living room John in the corner if I told
you this time yeah and uh I love
shortiest stories yeah well I am good at
these so the long story short John from
Pittsburgh and John here in the studio
is uh we had a leak uh in the winter
time
uh it was the corner of the roof right
in the living room and I started to see
one night a little bubbling up uh you
know and I was like uh-oh and we'd had
heavy rain for two or three days and so
I went up like Clark Griswold up in the
ceiling in the Attic and made it all the
way across walked across the boards you
know in my moccasins like a complete
idiot you know and I saw where the leak
was okay it's not a disaster but we've
got a we got a nail hole or something I
have to call the roofer
and on my way back
yeah you know where this is going don't
you John right through yeah I uh I had
some Flex Seal that I sprayed you know
that guy that yells at you you can put
your boat back together I bought that I
thought well that'll keep it until and
so the cap wasn't on and so as I'm
walking across the uh the the the the
tube of you know the uh the joys floor
joists I looked at the cap and decided
to adjust the cap while I was walking on
the high wire and stepped through my
ceiling
about broke my leg I mean it was
disastrous I'm not kidding you like half
my leg is hanging through our living
room ceiling
um you know that kind of stuff can
happen that's right you know and so
there were several damages you know
um that's what emergency fund is for
right there that's what the emergency
fund is for because I needed it fixed
immediately and we hadn't budgeted for
it we could have cash flowed it moved
the budget around the point is small
amount but I hate touching my emergency
funds makes me crazy so John I totally
get where you're at I always like to
replenish that emergency fund when we
have to use it almost immediately
because I hate using it however in this
case don't pause the baby steps you're
going to replenish it pretty quickly
okay now what about the upgrade of the
house which is like a 3B kind of thing
do we pause to because we feel like
we're close to the way the market is in
our area but we're we need a little bit
more we feel down payment to get to the
15-year mortgage
if you think you can do it in six months
I'd be all right with it if you think
you can do it quickly that's my question
I think we could do it in six months if
you could do it six months and you just
want to hit the gas on this real quick
thing fine yeah I said so because you
talk about college investing and then
your normal 15 is that what you're
talking about yes correct is that free
up a good bidder if we just went like
back to like gazelle intense for six
months like we were we could have cash
to get into that yes but I want you all
to write it down and I want you to
commit to a Blood Oath because here's
the deal whenever you give somebody a
little bit it's like a little bit of
wiggle room you're going to find
yourself going out to eat five nights a
week and doing this and let's go ahead
and buy this house instead of this right
see what I'm saying so to put the plan
down six months my wife and I okay let's
stick this six months and then we'll get
back here come what may we're doing this
right and maybe even go to into your um
to your HR representative at your at
your office and say for six months then
we want it to automatically trigger back
to start the withdrawal again or
whatever that looks like but take it out
of your hands as much as possible and
y'all commit we're gonna we're gonna
look at this every week to make sure
we're staying on this thing but if you
think you can knock it out in six months
I'm okay with pause and stuff but don't
do it much longer than that man because
you're gonna end up costing yourself
down the road
right okay yeah and hey I would re-adopt
that gazelle intensity that you guys you
know distribute uh uh
that you guys displayed to get where you
are so it's a Sprint we're not going out
to eat we're not buying stuff we're
gonna have a very sparse Christmas we're
just gonna knock this out yep because
listen I get where you're at too on the
townhouse and the kids and everything
but again you can create a an urgency
that's really not urgent it's a
manufacturer the kids are fine you know
and I get it you want to separate them
and get them in different rooms I get
all that but take your time you don't
want to sacrifice John laid that out
beautifully so hey man great job
congratulations on being debt free and
working the baby steps and this is a
really great call John uh really really
really happy for you guys and that's
that's why the baby steps are so
brilliant even in their Simplicity
they're building just simply they just
give you you understand this about human
behavior talk about the power of
Riverbanks you know to have okay this is
where I'm running well I think that's I
think we as a culture are wrestling with
that because we don't like them and now
we've got this tiny little sliver in
human history when we can temporarily
avoid all boundaries we can just make it
up as we go you don't like the way you
look fix it you don't like the car you
just borrow some money you just go fix
it we are living in we're trying to live
in a boundary-free life the problem is
as the great vessel Van Der kolk says
the body's keeping the score we're not
designed to live without boundaries and
it's frustrating to submit to that and
we've got scientists trying to
um
to smooth out all Bank Riverbanks right
let's just let this thing just go any
way we want to whatever you feel like
just go
ultimately we got to live within the
boundary span and it's frustrating and
boundaries have been used throughout
history to abuse people I get that and
at the same time math is just math man
it just is peace is just peace and you
can you can play outside the boundaries
all you want man but it's going to come
at a cost and so I I identify with this
this guy so much you get through and
then it's like ah now I finally want
this cup you mean I gotta go two more
years to save up for this car that I
want yep and it's just adopting those
principles for the Long Haul yeah over
and over and over again oh it's
frustrating but that's good life John
you're a stud borrow the name from that
great football franchise in Pittsburgh
and steal your resolve you guys got this
you got the plan and you've done it big
thanks to my colleague Dr John Delaney
thinking James and the entire team
behind the booth but most importantly
thank you America for watching and
listening this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
just launched a brand new audience
survey for the Ramsay show and we'd love
your feedback you know to win a 500 Visa
gift card no purchase necessary take the
survey at ramsesolutions.com survey
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsey Show it's where America hangs out
to have a conversation about your life
specifically your money your
relationships your mental health your
work
I'm Kim Coleman joined by my colleagues
Dr John deloney the phone number to jump
in is triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go to
Craig in Indianapolis Indiana Craig how
can we help
hey Ken John thanks for taking my call
you bet
um just a little background 2005 we got
hooked up with arrange Ramsey's baby
steps and
went through the process and we're now
uh in baby step seven and
uh baby steps millionaires way to go
nice
but
here's a couple months back I got
terminated from a job of 26 years
on a policy violation and going forward
I want to know how to
approach that subject in an interview
because I know the question can be asked
how did you leave your last job ah what
was that what what are you comfortable
sharing on this policy violation yeah I
think it will help my life it was I was
I think it was misapplied but it was a
racial discrimination
and it was it was definitely misapplied
and but I had no recourse in the end of
the right to work state so you can get
fired for any reason
so how can I go to the next interview
how do I when I ask that question I want
to be up front
but how do I do that without
laying myself out
I will tell you that there are very few
questions
that truly stumped me and and for the
moment I'm stumped in that this is such
a red flag for obvious reasons
um yeah certainly you understand
um you you you do need to be up front
um
but you're but you know it sounds to me
like okay so let me go back before I
tell you what I think you should say
you're telling me that
um it's your word versus their word
they're saying you violated something
and you're saying I did not do it are
you are you basically saying this was a
misunderstanding
no it wasn't a misunderstanding the
company got hit with a fairly
significant case a couple years back and
they are just hypersensitive to this
stuff
and it doesn't take and it literally
took almost nothing to trigger this
right but and I don't want you to share
what you said because I don't want to be
insensitive to anybody but was this
something you said or something you did
oh something that was posted you posted
something on your uh social media
yeah it was it was a group chat and I
posted something and it
it was taken the wrong way I didn't even
imply it to be the way it was one person
took it and that's how it okay let me
ask you this if you're in a job
interview in the near future and uh
would you feel comfortable showing what
you posted to anybody from any Walk of
Life absolutely you would you would have
you would push it across the table
previous co-workers say what happened
because they're being real quiet about
it and I've had previous co-workers
asking well what happened we understand
why why you're gone so and I show them
they're like they shake their head they
just but in disbelief that I was
terminated over that well then part of
me says that you know because if you
start getting too gray about this
they're going to check your references
you have to assume that that they're
going to check your references and so
what you don't know are Stellar I mean
even my supervisors and everything will
give me the utmost highly High
recommendation okay wait a second I know
you're chomping at the bit but but let
me let me ask you this if if you go
interview for a company ABC all right
and they call your past company where
you were terminated
you're telling me that the people who
terminated you are going to say
great things about you and they're going
to say manage management terminated me
not my direct supervisor
okay but my point is is that you're
going to have to plan for this so I
don't want to get cute I don't want to
try to describe
or coach you on some sort of dance I I
think you're going to have to deal with
this so I think you're going to have to
have your post and I'd print it out and
I would say here's what happened and
I've learned now here's the deal
I would show them the post
and then I would also say here's what
I've learned even if you stand by what
you posted even if you think that you
were wrongly terminated or that you were
misunderstood or somebody was too
sensitive it doesn't matter I would go
here's what I posted
here it is here's who I am here's what I
learned and I would just own it and say
but for 26 years I had a stellar
performance and then I would just focus
on the positives why you want to be
there I just don't John am I missing
anything yeah here's the one thing Craig
is bothering me is
you're you have a very victim-centric
mentality
okay how so
well I I don't even know I just and even
if that you said it best get even if
that's how it happened it comes across
as manipulative and disingenuous
and so I I love Ken's idea when you go
for an interview you should have a
padfolio of some sort put it print it
off and put it in there and if you get
down that granular then have the
conversation and I love what Ken said if
you didn't learn something
from The Exchange
if you didn't learn hey I hurt
somebody's feelings and I didn't not
even mean to I'm learning new things
which by the way I've done over the past
36 months and I learned new things even
if I think I didn't mean to hurt it
doesn't matter what I meant the person
on the other end of what I said said hey
that hurt please don't do that and I can
do one of two things be an idiot and go
almost sick or I can say dude I don't
want to hurt you I'm sorry I'm gonna
change that and so you walking away
saying what did you learn I learned that
um things that I think are private on
the internet are public and so I'm going
to be more responsible about what I post
I'm gonna have some friends that I reach
out to if I hurt their feelings and say
Hey did I say this the right way or the
wrong way like right so regardless of
what happened
it's the well I don't know just
management man take some ownership right
I posted something I got fired for it I
learned my lesson and I'm moving forward
I'm a good guy I got 26 years of track
record I have no in absolutely nothing
in my body wants to hurt other people
and I did I crossed a line that my
company said I crossed the line I didn't
think I did but I did and I've learned
my lesson like you see what I'm saying
that is ownership I'm taking this I'm
sliding across the table totally
differently yeah all Shooks man I don't
know you see what I'm saying
yeah so you see here's what we're doing
we're saying take the elephant out of
the room absolutely you start acting
like a politician you know on those
Sunday morning shows they ask him a
direct question is the Sun hot and then
they start going well it depends on the
position this guy talks about rain all
the time I didn't ask you that so I
would just completely own it that way
and uh John I love the advice there's
something to be learned oh and I love
the I love what you said don't take on
the role of victim no because you're
trying to present yourself as a great
candidate and here's what they really
care about they're they're only want to
know one thing
and only one thing Craig you ready can
Craig help us win yep and if they think
that Craig can help us win they'll go
you're higher this is a guy that messed
up and learned something this is a guy
that that uh somebody messed him over
and he still learned something yeah
that's the guy on my team you're fine
Craig no shame in your game head high
but take humility into the conversation
it's gonna be okay thank you for uh
trusting us with the call you're gonna
be okay this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back America you have joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman joined by Dr John deloney
taking your phone calls about money
your relationships work situations how
do I get unstuck whether it's
relationally financially or
professionally that's what we're here to
help you with the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to Buffalo New York Adam
is there Adam how can we help
hey guys how are you doing here today uh
we're having a blast how are you sir
not too bad a little stressed so hoping
you guys can help me out here all right
um just to give you a little bit of
background here so uh earlier this week
my my mother came to me and asked me to
help her with their finances doing a
monthly budget and getting things in
order as well too I'm going over some
general information with her I found out
that they have about 65k in debt but
they're also looking to retire in the
next three to five years
um and I told them to go to a financial
advisor they're a little untrusting of
people outside the family when it comes
to money so I'm just looking for some
information something that I can relay
back to them as far as how to kind of
get out of this step before they go
looking to get into retirement sure how
familiar are you with our baby steps
uh very familiar I'm actually following
myself right now great are they familiar
with Dave and and the Ramsay show and
financial peace and or any of this stuff
or is this all foreign to them
kind of I brought that up to her when we
initially talked and I found out all
this found out all this information so
it's relatively new to them okay give us
a quick snapshot of their financial
picture how um uh you said 65 000 in
debt how much do they make collectively
uh collectively uh a year probably 100K
so 100K and do they have 401ks pension
plans what what do they currently have
in the form of retirement accounts
yeah and retirement account they
probably have around 400 uh 400k in
their 401ks uh and then with pensions
combined when they do retire they'll
probably be making 2100
um 2100 a month with other pensions and
what's their housing situation
uh the house is paid off for but they do
have a home equity loan that the 65k is
tied up in right now okay and then what
is the rest of the 65k home equity loan
what else
home equity loan uh with the home equity
loan they put
um a couple I believe like five ten
years ago they redid their kitchen uh
which is probably I believe around
between 30 to 50 okay I don't have that
oh okay I'm sorry so so the 65 is just
the HELOC
there's nothing outside of that
correct oh okay gotcha all right
um well I mean what you've got to sit
down with them and and you got to sit
down and explain the the baby steps to
them right I mean just literally walk
them through this baby step one is the
thousand dollars uh in their savings
account and then everything else and
they're they're obviously older so
gazelle intensity to go we're paying off
the HELOC right everything is it's 165
000 snowball we're getting after right
and so we just got to take that on every
month and they've got you know x amount
of years that they want to retire and so
that paid for a home plus their 401K uh
and the pension all puts them in a
pretty decent space if they have no debt
and they were to knock that out quickly
and start investing as quickly as
possible would you say that's true is
there some
yes definitely and what I'm wondering is
is do they stop investing in their 401k
and basically the money that they're
putting into the 401K invest that into
the into the debt and once they knock
that off absolutely yeah they pause they
pause on that because they have a paid
for house right and they've got a
pension coming their way so pause
everything and they are knocking this
out and walk them through this help them
with the budget if they'll if if they're
willing and I don't hear that there's
any tension on this sit down with them
and do a basic budget with them walking
through FPU and get them hooked up on
every dollar literally do it with them
and get them automated to where every
extra dime is going into that HELOC and
they'll knock that out pretty quickly
and if if either one of them can get
some overtime or some side work or how
much could you sell do they have 10 15
grand of stuff laying around the house I
mean that's the gazelle intensity to try
to knock this out sooner rather than
later
gotcha yeah and they have about four
grand in their savings account
um should we drain that down to the one
the 1K that you guys you know talk about
with babysat dub number one put that
towards the 65k and then book two invest
in that later yep today so now they're
down to 62. show them that and Adam I
always start the conversation with you
guys have this end goal of retiring
sooner rather than later you're going to
have to change the way you live to do
this safely and smartly
and stuff like that as well too and
tension on their their you know their
marriage as well so I just want to see
them financially free and get back to
the after you go lucky yourself as they
are you know you can't want this more
than they do
correct you want them to have the
freedom you're feeling as you walk
through this stuff and you want them to
have the optimism that you have walking
through this stuff and they have to want
it you can't force it on them you can't
make them do it you can show them
reality which is you've got a math
problem here and you're all gonna have
to change your lives a little bit if you
want and here's what retirement's gonna
look like by the way here is your budget
so when my mom was talking about hey I'm
thinking about starting to have a
conversation about retirement the first
question I asked was can y'all afford to
do that because you want to retire all
you want that's a math problem first and
then an identity and what am I going to
do next problem second so when someone's
like I'm thinking about return first
question is can you even is that even a
possibility for you and some people
think they just magically can retire
when they get to 62 or 65 and the math
says otherwise right
gotcha yeah Adam you're you're a good
man
um
hang on the line Let's uh let's give
them with a year of Financial Peace
University let's get them going and uh
John that's great advice tell them to
watch the videos together yeah I was
gonna say how does he how does he
approach that he's going to gift them
with us it's our gift to him to give to
his parents what's the great way to kind
of posture that I'm coming over to watch
this with you oh okay good I'll come
watch it with you great and here's what
I'm doing in my house and it's making a
huge difference you've invited me into
this conversation
um and so I'm just going to show it to
you I'm gonna give you ring Scentsy to
it I'll do it with you yeah I love it
great great thanks for the call Adam
you're a good good son Dennis is up in
El Paso Texas Dennis how can we help
hey guys uh so I am struggling with
something that my wife and I have been
going back and forth on for probably
about a year or maybe even longer
um
so we we became completely debt free uh
March of last year and we live in a a
small home you know that we didn't
didn't plan on staying in permanently uh
we thought it would be you know a few
months out of the year and so the
question is we would like to upgrade and
go to a little bit larger home uh with a
thought of we have a rental property
right now uh and would also rent the one
that we live in currently
um I'm wondering what you all would do
in my position where uh would you take
out a mortgage
on a new home you'd go live in and
collect more rental because there'd be
two rentals instead of one uh property
or would you save up for let's say six
years because currently that's our plan
but we keep getting tempted uh when we
look at homes it's like oh we start
imagining getting excited and it's like
oh we can actually probably make this
work and
um we always say what would Dave Ramsey
say and so finally making this phone
call uh and really appreciate all taking
the question
yeah we only have about a minute I think
this is pretty straightforward do you
want to own two rental homes or do you
want to own that next home completely
debt free from the get-go what do you
want
I'd like to have the rental and pay off
that other home as soon as possible
well I didn't ask you that yeah I asked
you and so I think you wait six years if
it's going to take you six years to save
up to pay cash for the upgrade then
that's the deal
I wouldn't hold two liabilities and pay
the the mortgage company or pay the bank
give them a gift every month of my
interest well I don't know why you would
do that yeah you've done the hard work
you're debt free right or sell the sell
the rentals and go buy a house with cash
but that's why I asked the question that
way Dennis what's more important if it's
the upgrade cash house is more important
then I'm selling one of the rentals
instantly we're selling most exactly
right but if I want to own two Cash
Rentals that that's more important than
it means I'm going to save up and wait
longer to buy the upgrade right you get
to decide but don't go into debt
free don't go back you don't need to
decide what you want
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John delones by colleague and
he joins me this hour the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five if you want to jump in triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so John this is fun every once in a
while we will take a question from the
lobby and today we've got a returning
friend she and her family were here
yesterday doing their debt free scream
and she joins us again in the lobby
today but this time a work related
question it's Angelica did I say that
correct yes all right welcome back thank
you again now before we get to your
question this is kind of rare are you
were on that stage yesterday with your
family doing your debt free scream now
you're back a day later how does it feel
this time I still I think a double
nervous my husband's not here next time
so you know what you got me and John not
Dave so like Dave Dave's scary isn't he
no I think he was free you know yeah I'm
not joking we just got to give him a
hard time he's the best he's great all
right so you've got a work-related
question for John and I what's up okay I
have been living in a country for over
90 years and in my work background is in
supply chain okay so in the past 10
months and I started uh reevaluating my
work situation I have been working as a
paralegal but now I want to go back to
my supply chain field that's my dream
job it's have always been and I started
to get re-qualified to stand out a
little bit but I still have found a lot
of struggle to
um to even find the internet level jobs
positions um I have a bank recruiter and
some interviews in person over the phone
or zoom and still have a really hard
time people would still like give me a
hard time for The Gap that have been
working my field and
be doing something totally different
between all those years and yeah that's
my my really concern I don't know how
what else can I do to stand out okay so
just to make sure I understand you are
getting real feedback that you've had a
did you say nine year gap between when
you've been in supply chain yes and yet
you've also gotten some recent
qualifications and some certifications
that make you current exactly okay uh
how many interviews have you been on
where you've had at least a face-to-face
whether it would be Zoom or in person
where they've given you that feedback
that the Gap is too much okay and the
the Gap they took a couple interviews
over the phone orders was more in person
and over the zone and they still like to
say like why you you know so long this
time here and say I I feel so wet they
are wasted my time as well because they
instead okay if you if give me
opportunity to be in person
uh why don't let me stand up and and
show that I have the skills and mindset
to move forward and but still yeah don't
even give me a feedback to say okay
what's what's not working here how many
of those interviews that you've gotten
have have you had a personal connection
maybe where they knew you through
somebody else or they knew you directly
have any of those been the case Zero all
right that's our new strategy all right
so first of all you're not done anything
wrong okay secondly I wouldn't take uh
too much from that feedback okay because
here's the reality whether you've been
out 19 years or nine years
okay and you're a supply chain expert
you know what that work involves the
fact of the matter is you didn't forget
how to do it in that nine years time all
right uh I would also guess and correct
me if I'm wrong that a successful person
in supply chain and Logistics uh you're
using a lot of those same skills and
experience as a paralegal I would guess
yes details details are very orientating
yeah so here's the deal I I just would
not be discouraged and I know it's
discouraging but I don't think it's
personal I think you're getting a lot of
corporate speak they didn't select you
for whatever reason and so what you've
got to do is go to in order to get back
in
I've got to change my strategy and I
wrote an entire book on this I'm going
to give it to you after the question
we'll come out on the break and give it
to you it's called the proximity
principle and here's what it says in
order to do what I want to do supply
chain work
I've got to start hanging around being
around people that are in that business
that type of work and I got to get in
places where that kind of work is
happening right so maybe that's uh
groups and forums and things like that
online where people are supply chain
leaders and they're looking for talent
and there's all these best practices
going on there's a community for
everything would you agree with that yes
there's a community for everything find
it secondly we start looking at
companies in your area where are you
from Massachusetts okay great so we
start going okay where are the supply
chain companies and jobs where are those
at all right now so I start looking at
Targets maybe even places that you've
applied to but you haven't gotten hired
this time we're looking for that
one-to-one connection or one two or
three connections meaning if I don't
know someone if I don't know John who
works over at company ABC where John
could take my resume and not just take
my resume but say I've known Ken for x
amount of time he was out for nine years
here's why he's back in he's a really
great guy I think he's somebody we
really need to look at do you see how
that's a whole different ball game it's
relational credibility and to get back
in that's what we need here so that
there's a perception of you before you
ever step into the interview that you're
somebody that has credibility through
relationship and now all of a sudden you
got the upper hand does that make sense
it does that's what we've got to do
right now you can get back in but you're
up to date on all your certifications
you're updated on everything so this is
relationship so who do I know that works
over here or who do I know that knows
somebody so you're shaking the tree all
right when I was a little kid we used to
go to a farm in Michigan where my
grandfather lived he had the apple tree
and he'd go all right boys go get the
apples and we were just tall enough to
grab the lower branches and he'd say
just shake this is the idea we're
shaking the apple tree to get as many
opportunities through relationships that
are connected to the jobs we want okay
John
how you look defeated sure
why why are you defeated
I I feel um like it's really hard for me
to prove that I'm worth it you know some
I listen to your old show as well like
it's hard because
I I said a lot in Brazil yeah I have a
lot of work background like um
qualification guy here and I started odd
jobs
just to surviving I have my family get
out of that and
now I really want to go back to my field
and I feel like my time is kicking and
I'm way so much time just it's hard it's
hard
um
so one of my most important mentors is a
guy named Gustavo okay and Gustavo came
to United States he married a missionary
he came to the United States and had 200
bucks in his pocket in an old Ford
pickup and he was an engineer in a South
American country
and the US wouldn't recognize his
engineering degree and he had to feed
his family so he ended up sweeping the
floor at a cotton gin in West Texas okay
and he got so fed up he started
um changing people's oil in their
driveway he was a lovely guy and I met
you and you're a lovely human being you
just exude Joy right you're somebody I
want to hang out with right and
he turned that Mobile Oil Change
business into a juggernaut
and he gave he was a time machine for me
and my family you know what he gave me
time with my son that I couldn't buy
here's why I tell you that
unfortunately we live in a world where
people may not give you another chance
or you're gonna have to like Ken says
it's gonna be six months of shaking that
tree before an apple finally Falls you
are too brilliant and two two you if you
were so effusive in your joy it just
comes across in who you are
um
I would love to see you not Outsource
your Worth to somebody some some HR
representative at some nameless company
I'd rather you look in the mirror and
say I will provide value regardless of
whether they find it or they find it or
they find it because eventually it's
going to circle back because that's who
you are right you're in you don't be
beat up and I know it sounds dumb but
don't let me see this you got beat up
don't be defeated does that make sense
yeah and so whether you got to start
coming up with the Arts and Crafts thing
like I want to get back to the supply
chain Logistics well cool that I'm just
gonna build my own freaking company or
hey let me add something what if you go
get an administrative position
that's way beneath you get in the door
but you're inside the company of that
that has the supply chain jobs and now
all of a sudden they know here's the
only reason you haven't gotten hired
the people that were interviewing you
didn't dig deep enough they didn't maybe
they saw somebody else maybe it was
easier has nothing to do with you it's
all about them they're boneheads let me
put this out to the audience if you're
anywhere near the Boston Massachusetts
area and you work at a supply chain
company will you call Ramsey care you're
not doing a bang-up job as it is
logistics people yeah we've got a great
solution right right here I'll write the
recommendation letter what's wrong with
you
you got this your time will come but you
got to keep at it keep on keeping on you
hear me
you're amazing it's gonna work out this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the ribs show America
I'm Kidd Coleman he's Dr John deloney
we're thrilled to be with you triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the phone number uh triple eight
eight two five five two thank you John
John's reminding me of something I was
getting there I promise I'll I'll finish
the number though triple eight eight two
five five two two five our scripture of
the day show yourself in all respects to
be model of good works and in your
teaching show Integrity dignity that's
Titus 2-7 and our quote of the day from
George Foreman
the fighter who gives their all will be
around next year don't save anything
give it all you got begs the question
John uh have you ever cooked on a George
Foreman grill absolutely so I
Stacy made me get rid of it what I loved
it our first two years of marriage we've
lived on the former Grill dude that
thing was amazing
got all the grease out when you're
cooking burgers and stuff yeah she
thought it was kind of like really and I
was like I think it's fantastic it's one
of the great office episodes of all time
too
but he steps on the grill so true legend
oh it's so good Bernie is up next in San
Francisco California Bernie how can we
help
you fellas uh it's good to talk to you
good to talk to you how can we help
yeah so a long story short uh I'm gonna
be step five here and I'm just really
unenthusiastic about it like
what makes you unenthusiastic about it
it's just like I guess I just having
kids dude do you think everyone should
do that or at least pay for it it just
seems like a lot of lacking peace do you
I'm sorry do you have kids
oh I don't oh are you asking us if if
you should have kids
oh I'm asking if I should do step five
uh right now I'm 23. since you don't
have okay that's what I was wondering so
oh yes kids will take all your money and
they're loud and they pee everywhere oh
and that's the truth and they're
incredible the return on investment is
not great they're not an investment
brother but but hey you're 23 and the
fact that you're asking that question
says don't have kids anytime soon yeah
you're good sure I mean is that John's I
think John's nailed it you're not
thinking about kids anytime soon is that
right Bernie
dude no yeah don't save for college for
kids that you may or may not have yeah
you're not there yet yeah keep on
trucking do you own a home
uh that was the other things so instead
should I start saving for a down payment
on a home yeah yes absolutely kind of
far off too 100 absolutely now that that
for sure yes
okay yeah congratulations I mean what
else would you be doing yeah I I don't
know that's you're not gonna put it in a
coffee can and bury it in your backyard
hey you're not uninspired with money
you're uninspired just with life what
are you doing
I don't think I work I do a lot of
volunteering stuff actually with
students um I don't that's not what I'm
asking you're miserable why why are you
choosing a life of misery of uninspired
and uninspired life why are you choosing
that
you know
I've never really thought of it that way
uh life is kind of peaceful right now
actually I don't think he's miserable
John are you not you feel good Bernie
oh yeah feeling good volunteers
I'm sorry you volunteer you give back
you're discipline with money but I think
John is on to something I mean I just
don't think at 23 you've got a Grand
Vision for your life yet is that fair I
think that's accurate like what am I
doing here I think I asked myself that
this morning man it's that's just the
question yeah
um what are you doing here
uh I don't know like if I look in my my
long-term future I really kind of just
want to keep keep volunteering like I
really like working with those students
what warms your heart why do you keep
volunteering with kids what's what's
driving that
yeah I work with high school age kids so
you know they're at a point where
they're figuring out what do I do after
high school do I go to college do I not
like all that type of stuff and so I'm
seeing like success or at least peace
brought into their life and if I can
contribute to that piece which makes me
really happy yeah but I think it's I
think it's deeper than that because
you're a guy that doesn't know what he
wants to do with his life so it's not
like you're imparting tremendous wisdom
what are you coaching them on I I I
think it's something deeper there Bernie
and I think even more beautiful what is
it about
spending time with those kiddos that
fires you up
yeah you do you know
yeah but do you make me happy like to
take me back to a moment recently last
time you volunteered
that when you walked back to your car
and got in the car and drove wherever
you drove you you thought about that
moment that interaction can you think of
one of those
yeah give me describe it to John and I
um yes I just had a kid uh his father
her father passed away and so we all
went to the funeral and just
um I just remember like how seeing how
hard it was for them but I guess just
even just being there I didn't have to
say much uh it was enough to just kind
of give a hug and be present for others
yeah it's the single greatest gift you
can give somebody which is your presence
right your time it's incredible who did
that for you
somebody modeled this for you when I was
in high school a lot of the history
church just for context so a lot of
those same mentors would come out from
you in that kind of way
can I tell you that I think a part of
your Grand Vision
and I don't want to put any pressure on
the statement this is just me hearing
what I heard and John tell me if I'm not
hearing what because John's very
insightful on this I hear a guy who you
need to whether it's volunteer or
Ministry time a huge portion of your
future life
is in a role where you are just there
for people
I'm keeping that broad on purpose
because I don't want to in the emotion
of the moment where you're a chaplain or
a therapist or like you show me very
broad right but I think your
professional future is in that area I
think you have a huge heart for people
and I'm going to take a guess that
you're really good with people is that
true or false tell me where I'm off
uh yeah no I think everything you said
is accurate um in my day-to-day work
it's in software so I really don't help
anyone or the world if you will so yeah
well okay now hold on yes you do yes you
do because the software that you are
involved in has a positive effect on
people somewhere somehow true or false
that's true all right so don't say that
again
but I will say I will say this as a
challenge
I think you've got to be in the people
work space I think working with people
is your jam
it does I think I think that's important
because I think your soul will slowly
slip out of you if you are not
interacting with people I'm going to say
75 of the day I think you are good with
people and I think you want to work with
people I think it fires your soul up so
there's a broad broad spectrum here
coaching teaching instructing counseling
I mean dude this could be Health Care
this could be mental health this could
be educational it could be it could be
business you could go sell stuff the
products that people that change
people's lives and you get to develop
relationships it could be all over the
place man yeah sure I I just want you to
dream in that aspect so here's what I'm
going to do I'm going to give you the
get clear career assessment that uh our
team developed I'm going to give this to
you because I want you to take it I want
you to really focus in on what comes up
on passion and Mission passion is what
you love to do and Mission is what
motivates you and I think we already
know I think I think acts of service
fire your soul up
and so I think I think I've got a
three-part question that'll help you and
here I'm going to give you homework
assignment will you promise to do it
I'll do it sir all right here's the deal
I want you to answer these three
questions as many times as it takes
maybe use a pencil so you can erase and
keep doing it who are the people I most
want to help
the second question
what is the problem or desire that those
people have
it's very important that you you ask it
that way sometimes it's problem based
with the people we want to help and
sometimes it's desire based right so
I've talked to people before they want
to be a hairdresser why they want to
make women feel beautiful
so that's a desire you could sell shoes
design clothing so what is the problem
those people have because you've already
thought of the people now the third
question is first question is what is
the problem I most want to solve excuse
me who are the people I most want to
help what problem or desire they have
and then the third question is what are
the solutions or what is the solution to
that problem or desire that I most get
excited about did you get those three
yes I wrote them no it's all the same
question I'm just having you ask it from
a different perspective and I think the
answers to that to those questions are
going to steer you in a really good
direction
John and so your money is a reflection
um your money is a reflection of where
you are and how you feel so if your
money's feeling uninspired look in the
mirror don't look at your dollars look
in the mirror and don't
um save money for kids yeah man you're
not quite there for sure you're not
quite there yet guy called to ask about
baby step five and we just broke his
future down but he's a good dude
everybody that spends times with
teenagers yep gets my vote for greatest
person on the planet I love it they're
tough good man John Delaney you're a
good man thanks for hanging with me and
I want to thank James Kelly the entire
team in the booth and you America for
listening and watching this is the
Ramsey Show
Dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the Ramsay show and
we'd love your feedback
when a 500 Visa gift card
just necessary take the survey at
ramsesolutions.com survey
[Music]